jean luc mélenchon dénonce la gestion de
la production de vaccin contre le coc
vie de 19 par l'industrie pharmaceutique
et appelle à la levée des brevets sur
les vaccins l'idée selon lui est de
permettre à d'autres entreprises de
fabriquer le vaccin et mettre un terme à
un enrichissement sans cause des
entreprises pharmaceutiques
sauf que le patron de la france
insoumise fais tu ici une confusion
qu'est ce qu'un brevet le brevet bien il
permet à celui qui l'a déposé freezer ou
astrazeneca par exemple d'obtenir un
monopole d'exploitation se son intention
concrètement celui qui a inventé le
vaccin est le seul à pouvoir le produire
en temps normal le brevet protège
l'inventeur et lui permet de
rentabiliser ses investissements
il favorise donc l'innovation et sans
cette protection légale
on attendrait toujours le vaccin contre
le coc vie 19 mai lorsque sont en jeu
des questions de santé publique
ce monopole peut paraître injuste voire
problématique
la loi prévoit donc ce qu'on appelle des
licences d'office
ce mécanisme permet à l'état d'obliger
les titulaires de brevets a cédé une
licence d'exploitation à d'autres
fabricants afin de satisfaire un besoin
général mais contrairement à ce que dit
jean luc mélenchon la licence d'office
n'est pas une suppression du brevet
encore moins une config une confiscation
ou une nationalisation du brevet c'est
une licence d'exploitation en échange
d'une rémunération et qui n'empêchera
pas les laboratoires pharmaceutiques de
continuer à produire et à vendre
lui-même son vaccin